hey guys it is the tenth of sep tember
today my name is jeff mcdonald and
you're watching games Putney's the voice
of radio DJ three dog in fallout 3 Eric
Todd Dellums tweeted out that he was
bewildered to have not been given the
opportunity to audition for a part in
fallout 4 back in 2013 dillons teased
that he may appear in the next fallout
game and at the time he said he was
authorized to make that comment
unfortunately he never received a chance
to audition and once Bethesda confirmed
that they finished voice recording and
he knew it wouldn't be happening he's
voiced the hope that his initial tweets
weren't to blame for him not getting a
part since at the time well at four was
still just a rumor microsoft has
announced that they're shutting down the
xbox live indie games program the
program let developers create own self
publish indie games on the Xbox 360
notable games to come out of the program
include blocks that matter and techno
kitten adventure Microsoft is no longer
accepting subscriptions and membership
renewals as they say more than 1,000
developers with kits in hand are working
on the next generation of games for xbox
one and Windows 10 Microsoft have said
that users with valid subscriptions can
pick up a free lifetime windows
developer account and projects already
in development will be supported until
sep tember of next year Microsoft have
said that you can reupload and play
games you own as normal and that I did
Xbox is considered to be the spiritual
successor to the program finally a new
Pokemon game has been announced it's
called Pokemon go and is coming to iOS
and Android devices Nintendo the pokemon
company and niantic revealed the
upcoming free-to-play mobile game where
you'll get to catch train and battle
pokemon in the real world are using the
gps tech in your mobile device meiotic
other developer of the augmented reality
MMO ingress and were formerly a part of
Google in Pokemon go you can either use
your phone or an optional device called
poker
goplus which is more on your person and
used to execute in-game actions and
connects to your phone using bluetooth
if you want to board the hype train you
can check out the trailer on site
Pokemon go will be out in 2016 let me
know down in the comments what your
thoughts are on today's stories and be
sure to head to gamespot where we've got
news on GTA 5 updates and the
best-selling PSN games of last month
that is everything I wanted to tell you
about today to remember the tomorrow
I'll have my top 5 best stories the
whole gaming week ready to go for you so
as to see them